okay it's time for this day in history
this day in history a topic near and
dear to my heart on this day in history
in 1961 the United States cut off
diplomatic relations with Cuba
I know it's terrible luckily the
president stockpiled all of his Cuban
cigars before that happened now after
two years of deteriorating relations we
closed our embassy in Havana
I love Cuba I traveled there for a
weekend in June with our senior producer
Jonathan hay and daily wire god-king
Jeremy boring
they have very delicious stogies their
beautiful peaches truly wonderful people
but the United States has bungled our
relations with that island ever since
Fidel Castro seized power in 1959 and
this has a lot to do with what we're
talking about today those errors almost
plunged the world into global nuclear
conflict during the Cuban Missile Crisis
these decisions say a lot about
confrontation and appeasement Bill
Buckley William F Buckley Jr when he
started the National Review founded the
modern conservative movement he refused
to support Dwight Eisenhower because he
considered him too soft on communism
Cuba is the prime example of that in
early 1960 Castro signed a trade treaty
with the Soviet Union in response the US
began funding and training group of
Cuban expats to overthrow the dictator
all well and good good to get a commie
outta there trouble is that campaign was
tempered it was moderate it was bit by
bit so Castro began stealing even more
private property to this day Cuba is
essentially a mafia nation as a mafia
run nation with the Castro's at the helm
with it all so in response then to that
the Castro's a stealing private property
including countless American interests
the US began to implement certain
cutbacks in trade with Cuba too little
too late two months later just a few
months into his presidency John F
Kennedy sent the Cuban exile force into
Cuba during the Bay of Pigs debacle it
was a major failure it was a major
setback for the Kennedy administration
just one year later the United States
entered into a 13 day standoff during
the Cuban Missile Crisis the closest the
50-year Cold War ever came to direct
nuclear conflict two big nuclear buttons
both of which worked on two separate
desks Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev
had met
four months earlier in his impression
was the Kennedy was weak again the
perception of weakness the perception
that these people had that this
superpower had lost its resolve he
installed missiles just 90 miles off
American shores with Fidel Castro
chomping at the bit to launch them how
many times had the Us Weekly challenged
Castro tried to assassinate have tried
to invade in fact many historians credit
Castro's hotheadedness with helping to
convince Khrushchev to back off now as a
result of this bungled foreign policy
the United States was forced to remove
our missiles from Turkey though
fortunately nuclear war was averted what
should we learn from all of these
episodes past and present peace can only
be maintained with the credible threat
of force as Ronald Reagan put it peace
through strength Teddy Roosevelt said to
speak softly and carry a big stick
but sometimes you can't speak softly
sometimes you have to speak big Lee
especially on Twitter and in those cases
everybody needs to know that we have a
big button on our desks and it works